kelsey gabbard is one of the few people
in the democratic party who saw this
coming and was excoriated for it she's a
former congressman from hawaii she joins
us tonight congresswoman thanks so much
for coming on so i'm just trying to
think because i think it's a fair
question as an american what's in this
for me and my neighbors and the rest of
us and all i'm getting is that we can
feel morally satisfied because we hate
putin is there something that i'm
missing
uh no i don't think you're missing
anything the reality is that these
sanctions don't work whether they were
put in before or now or later these
sanctions don't work what we do know is
that they will increase suffering and
hardship for the american people and
this is the whole problem with the biden
administration they are so focused on
how do we punish putin
that they don't care and are not focused
on what is actually in the best
interests of the american people so when
biden stands there and looks directly
into the camera and says you know
defending freedom will cost us
what he really should be saying is
looking directly into the american
people's eyes and saying this will cost
you because these sanctions are not
going to cost him or kamala harris or
the power elite in this country even the
power elite in russia it is the people
who will suffer the american people the
russian people people here at home
working hard every single day facing
those drastically increasing prices at
the gas pump facing increasing costs at
the supermarket impacting our supply
chain the hardships that people are
dealing with every day now with biden
sanctions plan
we're only going to see that continuing
to get worse and it doesn't end there
tucker this is the problem is you think
russia russia's not going to respond you
think putin's not going to respond he
will respond and it's likely he'll
retaliate using cyber attacks on our
financial systems our communication
systems uh on our basic infrastructure
biden will then be forced to respond
putin will then be forced to respond so
we end up in this endless tit for tat
that leads us where to to this looming
threat and likelihood of this thing
going nuclear and again this is the
reality that we all need to understand
is true is that whether it is
intentional or unintentional when you
have two great nuclear armed countries
at this point of escalation and then if
there is a nuclear attack the power
elite these people are going to go hide
in their bunkers they'll have their
shelter they'll have their food and
water and everything that they need you
and i and the american people
we will be left out to deal with the
consequences to suffer and deal with
that destruction and death that will
come as a result
and yet we're doing this for principal
the people in charge who don't care at
all about our founding documents who
violate their spirit and letter every
day are telling us that an essential
american principle is at stake do you
have any idea what that principle might
be
that that therein lies the hypocrisy
tucker is they're saying we are doing
this in the defense of freedom in the
defense of democracy but these are the
very same people who are working to
undermine our own freedoms and our own
democracy right here at home i have a
hard time seeing how they actually say
these things with a straight face to the
american people when they clearly don't
care about these principles right here
at home they don't care about defending
them they don't care about the
well-being of the american people
i think that's all very clear and i
appreciate your saying it as clearly as
you did chelsea gabbard joining us
tonight thank you very much
it's it's interesting when people tell
you who you're required to be mad at
you've got a right to think for yourself
you should be mad at the people who are
making your life worse who are
preventing you from saying what you
think is true who are you calling you a
racist for no justification only to hurt
you who are destroying your children's
education who are allowing your country
to become polluted and overrun and
filled with drugs and the homeless maybe
you should be mad at them hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else